the trial of cattle and separatist
leaders over their failed independence
bid has laid bare some stark divisions
in Spanish society not least over the
justice system my guest this week here
in Madrid is Spain's foreign minister
jose eber el how does he answer the
charge that the trials are fundamentally
unfair
[Music]
user Borel
welcome to conflict zone thank you last
year a lady called kami Foucault was the
president of the Catalan Parliament
she was arrested charged with rebellion
when she was interviewed last December
she was spending 15 hours a day in her
cell in solitary confinement is this
really the image of Spain that you want
to show the rest of the world this is a
judiciary decision to the people under
control in order to avoid them to escape
from the justice like others a
grandmother in her mid sixties in a
prison convicted of nothing by the jury
what she enjoys the presumption of
innocence before her relationship
everybody who shall present the
preventive jail enjoys the presumption
of innocence in Sweden 30% of the people
who are in jail are on preventive
detention it's hard not to see her
incarceration as the action of a
vindictive state setting out to punish
defendants they should should be
enjoying this presumption of innocence
it had a presumption of innocence
preventive jail has nothing to do with
it you're on record as saying that you
wished some of those in pretrial
detention were free you said I said
exactly that I would had prefer that the
judge could have found another way of
preventing them from escaping the action
of justice you said there were other
methods that could have been used you
said there were other methods that could
have been used so this was unfair
treatment no in your view no no you'd
have preferred to see them out of
pretrial no nothing made me say things
that they haven't said Amnesty
International according to them the use
of pre-trial detention is justified only
when there is no alter
relative measure which would ensure the
interests of justice you have said there
are alternative measures so it is unfair
well look if the judge has decided to
implement this measure it's because he
thinks it has to do so I am NOT going to
decide in the place of judges in Spain
judges are independent and they take
their decision by their own I understand
sorry
and if maybe mr. put him on had an
escape
maybe they judge could have taken other
kind of measures do you know that wisdom
on and others has been escaping the
actual of justice do you know that there
are very few people who don't know that
on this move and them explain that but
it's not your role you tell me the
courts are independent but it's not your
role to turn a blind eye to serious
questions and doubts about the way your
judicial system is functioning isn't it
because you came to power your
government came to power promising to
transform and modernize Spain my point
to you is keeping people in lockdown in
solitary confinement for 58 hours a day
what do you mean by solitude solitude
finally 15 hours a day a 63 year old
grandmother convicted of nothing but
excuse me why do you say convicted of
nothing do you know about the conviction
on this case I start thinking that you
don't anything about it
she hasn't been convicted of anything as
she she's been charged but she has not
convicted well let's stop it you will
continue like this I you stop this
interview understand me if you continue
like this I just stop it and you are not
integrating me you are interviewing me
yeah you in me no I'm not of any kind of
enquire from your side I understand that
so I understand the right questions and
let me talk if not you stop it
absolutely okay
look you came to power to modernize and
registers again last year the EU
scorecard which measured public trust in
the independence of national courts and
judges put Spain in 23rd place on the
list of member countries below Portugal
Hungary and Romania how do you feel
about that a Spanish ranking among the
20 best democracies in the world
according with all the indexes that I no
intelligent unit of the economy The
Economist Freedom House I think it's
pain is being classified in all the
rankings as a being unfair democracy but
the truth is when it comes to the
charges of rebellion against the Catalan
defendants there has been a substantial
outcry both here and abroad hasn't that
last November more than a hundred legal
experts from in Spain signed an open
letter condemning the charge of
rebellion in the Catalan case that
didn't move you why don't you let the
judge has made their work I'm asking
your opinion
I'm the pinion is that in Spain
judiciary is an independent power let
them do their work how do you think that
the decision of the German Court which
refused to extradite the former Catalan
leader Carlos posed Amman on a charge of
rebellion how how do you think that has
affected the credibility of the case
against him because the German Court
said the amount of violence required for
the charge of high treason which is the
process they have to rebellion was not
seen in altercations in Spain breach of
the public peace they said does not
apply because Pilate Fujiyama was only
involved in carrying out the
independence referendum well these will
be
the German judge how you under the rule
of the Spanish judges and it's a blow to
your case isn't it
let's see would you the final decision
of the of the junii the course with the
court was basically saying that your
central charge against the Catalan
defendants doesn't hold up what's that
this is the opinion of the German judges
I don't know how much do they understand
about the situation in his pain but who
has to judge you the Spanish Court but
there are already suggestions here in
Spain that they're not going to get a
fair trial the professor of
constitutional law at Seville University
Javier Perez royal said I would like to
be wrong but the way in which the
October 1st case has proceeded so far
inevitably points to a guilty verdict
the trial will be a fast even though
they will abide by all the legal
procedures while it's been held but the
verdict has already been written it's a
chilling accusation hey Jo do everything
with him just that yes just that can you
don't agree with the association of
judges for democracy about the
appointment of some of the leading
figures in this case supreme interview
is very much bias we only look for the
people for criticizes the judges I can
tell you other people who have another
news they may not be other views but I
mean there's been damaging criticism
hasn't that look it's a third time I am
answering you the same answer in Spain
judiciary is an independent power let
them do their work
Carlos push the month accused you of
contributing to the increase in hate he
said when you were appointed foreign
minister is this the gesture they had in
mind in order to send us a message of
fraternal de-escalation the fact that
you have been you a Catalan have been
dead set against Catalonia independence
was he right was this a message of
fraternal de-escalation
can you tell me why mr. Poojah born is
saying these kind of things I can't I
can't read this man I'm asking buddy I'm
asking whether you agree with it no
pushy or not why should I try to defend
myself of the accusation when Mr
prettiman if you are unable to say on
which basis that said if you have we
have the slightest idea what you are
talking about do you want to de-escalate
the situation have been discarded in the
situation this government has been
making a big effort in order to
discourage the situation implementing
and the all kind of measures in order to
make things go into normal again but we
cannot give to the independency people
the right to the determination as they
are asking for because it is against the
Spanish Constitution and this has
nothing to do with international law why
not have a debate about the Constitution
and constitutional amendments that would
that could have touched on those
provisions which outlaw independence for
Spanish regions they could have done it
they could have gone to the Spanish
Parliament and present a proposal to
reform the Constitution but the Basque
did they haven't done it why didn't you
do it you are you not interested in
reforming the Constitution who is asking
for it 70% of Spaniards were no reform
according according to the Center for
sociological research 70% we have
continuously lying the Center for
sociological research has said that 70%
of Spaniards want constitutional reform
of some kind of some kind of some kind I
stopped it record it record
finish what no no finish I don't want to
do that anymore
[Music]
Minister in November the Human Rights
Commissioner of the Council of Europe
wrote to the Senate and the Congress of
Deputies pressing for serious amendments
to the so-called law on citizens safety
I know that your government promised
meaningful changes to this law but you
haven't delivered them have you I've
been visiting this the Consul and he
wasn't not complaining at all and he
said that the Spanish judiciary was
considerate and independent one and
performing according with human rights
law so there was no criticism at all you
didn't read the letter that was sent
yeah yeah but I had an interview with
them they went to talk with them and for
sure I don't think there is a criticism
about the functioning of the spend a
judiciary but you didn't you didn't
change the law did you
you promised meaningful changes to it
you haven't I don't know exactly what
you are talking about but in general
terms the consideration that the Human
Rights Council makes about the Spanish
system are very good what the
Commissioner wrote was in his letter I
find it disturbing that according to the
Minister of Interior in 2017 alone more
than 21,000 sanctions have been imposed
on the grounds of lack of respect or
consideration for police officers and
the articles that can easily be
interpreted he said in an arbitrary
manner and thus have a chilling effect
on freedom of expression well
you have a bias approach to the
situation in Spain what they can tell
you is that just human rights court has
had much less cases with respect to
Spain that to many other European
countries the Court of Human Rights
European Court of Human Rights decided
that a number of Basque separatists in
2010 didn't get a fair trial that they
you can follow that doesn't help your
argument does it no doesn't have my
argument from your point of view but I
can't repeat once and again that the
statistics shows that the Spain has much
less much much less cases in front of
the Court of Human Rights than many
other European countries like France
Belgium Germany and others but you don't
answer for them you answer for Spain are
you not concerned about this public
safety law you wanted to change it do
you find it satisfactory that so many
people were sanctioned for disrespecting
the police I am not aware of what you
were saying about I can't refer to the
statistics in general terms and the good
position that the Spain has on
respecting human rights let's talk about
arm sales minister in September last
year you announced you had halted the
sale of laser-guided bombs to Saudi
Arabia admit concerns over the use of
such weapons in the war in Yemen and
just days later you changed your mind
and said the contract had to be honored
why this contract is more contract was
higher it but since then it hasn't been
any more sell arms to Saudi Arabia but
you continue to sell arms not since this
government is in office we haven't sell
more arms you said you had changed your
mind and said this particular contract
had to be honored this particular
contract had to be I already was signed
by the previous government and that
Spanish socialist government believed
that
congrat had to be already angry on
audited yeah but these bombs munitions
of this kind have been used against
hospitals hotels water wells residential
buildings factories and last year and a
school bus attack so the question of
collateral damage when they've been
aimed at civilian targets doesn't really
apply does it what they said and
everybody who has a minimum intelligence
active youth can understand is that the
precision weapon creates less collateral
damages that bomb which is throw out
randomly yeah but if it's aimed at
civilian targets anyway that's just an
academic argument well if you read what
Human Rights Watch has said last year as
of November last year
6872 civilians had been killed and more
than 10,000 wounded by Saudi Arabia led
coalition airstrikes since 2015 they
have documented about 90 apparently
unlawful coalition airstrikes which have
hit homes markets hospitals schools and
mosques and these are the people you
decided to honor the contract with not
at all approve of what you are saying
that this was caused by this guy at
nerve arms well they were bombed these
were published coalition airstrikes I'm
trying to explain you're the only thing
I've said and it's something that you
have a little bit honest approach to the
problem you will understand that a
procedure bomb creates less collateral
damage that are random as a former
president of the European Parliament
I'm sure you've noted the criticism such
arms have attracted in that forum last
November
I mean peas heavily criticized the way
member states have green-lighted most
arms exports to Saudi Arabia despite the
fact that those exports violated six out
of eight criteria and thus undermine the
entire European arms control effort this
bush
that the space has been doing doesn't
fulfill completely all legal
requirements Amnesty International said
your own arms Export law prohibits arms
transfers when there is reasonable
suspicion they could be used in human
rights violations we have a committee
that controls the sport of arms and to
make sure that when we sport arms we
don't violate any rules and you are
confident despite criticism from human
rights groups despite what the EU
parliament has been saying about the
need to stop these arms exports to Saudi
Arabia that you haven't violated the
criteria I told you for at least two or
three times but you continue asking the
same question that it since this
government is in office we haven't
continuous ported arms so no more no
more laser-guided bombs to Saudi Arabia
now this was a contract that has to be
higher if it was signed by the previous
government and since then it hasn't been
another one I am asking the same
question minister at the time we have
left I'd like to look at developments
concerning Gibraltar your government has
made it clear that you intend to use the
brexit process to reopen the question of
shared sovereignty over Gibraltar
despite the fact that both Britain and
Gibraltar have signaled that that issue
is not open for debate why do you bother
bother about what to open the question
of shared sovereignty who says that your
Prime Minister did in November he said
that the issue shared sovereignty would
be back on the table all the time Prime
Minister Sanchez for sure it's on the
table all the time for you but it's not
for them
not for Gibraltar not for Britain for
sure and what so why do you think this
time you can put it back on the table
you think it's you can use the leverage
the leverage of brexit negotiations to
put pressure on Burton
you surprised how badly inform you are
lately you don't know anything about you
are talking about my god what don't I
know you did not and you don't know
anything about what you are talking
about we have been saying very clearly
that we were not going to use the talks
about black seed to put on the table the
question was a variety are you a liar oh
I just not wearing form and you didn't
hear your Prime Minister say in November
that the issue of shared sovereignty
would be back on the table but not
during the relaxedness oh she asians how
ignorant you are incredible what about
through the trade negotiations if there
is to be a free trade agreement between
Britain and Spain
what truth then will the again put
pressure on Gibraltar why do you say
these kinds of things I am very
surprised how did you come from do not
have the slightest idea what you are
talking about you say you say that and
you say that the issue is on the table
first of all you said that the
government had hasn't said anything
about putting it on the table then you
admit that progress the sentence did say
that can explain if you allow please
please if an answer to your continuous
question please please we have said very
clearly that we are not going to put the
question of sovereignty on the table on
the framework of the pledge the
negotiations and we haven't done it
which doesn't mean that we forget about
the question of sovereignty forever will
reach five agreement with the British
government about you broad which are
part for the withdrawal treaty and in
the future we also agreed with the
European Commission that any agreement
with United Kingdom with respect to
Gibraltar we have to be under the
control of the Spanish government that's
all nothing more than
for sure we'll keep the question of
sovereignty but it hasn't been put on
the table with respect to the production
negotiation you should know about it and
not put questions on a fourth way
February 18th Minister one of your
warships sailed into Gibraltar waters
and try to order out commercial vehicle
vessels that were tied up there what was
the point of that action because it's
forbidden for the ships to stop they can
pass that they cannot stop now these
were Gibraltar waters British to Malta
waters which you don't recognize we do
not recognize Gibraltar workers because
according with you h20 we learn the land
but not the waters we are acting
according with international treaty the
ships can pass by they cannot stop one
of your most experienced diplomats who
headed your mission and law of the sea
matters Jose Antonio de Tory Agha has
said publicly that there's no legal
basis for claiming that Gibraltar has no
territorial waters they did not divide
your view of the Spanish government it's
if you have a disagreement and you do
have this disagreement over Gibraltar
waters why not settle it through the
disputes procedure of the UN law on the
sea conference talks as far back as 1969
that's very night that you put question
it will be much better if you let the
interviewer to answer them please also
continually cutting my answers please
answer the question I told you for the
Spanish government the ships can pass by
but they cannot stop in the water that
we consider they don't belong for this
gibraltars for real but why not settle
that issue by dialogue by that why not
settle machine according by that why not
settle it right dialogue I underst
you don't answering my question minister
and ask the question that's many times
as you want
it's my answer what are you afraid of
dialogue taking it to international
arbitration to the International Court
of Justice they could decide this
international group of justice is not
competent for this kind of question and
the UN law of the sea they are competent
but you won't take it to them either you
want to put me in the bank of guilty
people no I'm just asking why not you
are very funny you are really funny
you've just reached the tax agreement
with Britain over Gibraltar
so dialogue can get some results contact
yes unlike with Gibraltar I said with
Britain I said with Britain region about
zero yes something wrong with it you
were concerned about tax fraud in
Gibraltar that's right why not do more
to prevent things like fraud and bribery
and money laundering anyway can'tcan't
Spain do more anyway you always can do
more transparency International says
that key European countries are failing
to enforce the OECD's anti-bribery
Convention which is one of the main
instruments for fighting global
corruption which is the question and
Spain is one of which is a question
Spain is one of them so currently
showing according to Transparency
International little or no enforcement
why is that we do as much as we can but
you could do more sure you could do
better good interview Minister good to
have you on conflict song thank you
thank you to you but next time I would
appreciate if you could the questions
and the last bias way I'm not here just
to give you the questions you want
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]